This video is brought to you by Skillshare.
What's up guys, Jared, here to talk about the movie that made the Oscars.
Cool again, that's right. Parasite a film. So mind-blowingly awesome.
It would leave even the most, her boasts cinema enthusiasts,
completely speechless at this point,
repeating praise for parasite and it's director bong Joon ho is kind of like
vaping. Everyone's doing it and it's kind of a waste of breath.
So we'll save any further gushing for our diary.
Parasite was celebrated all over the world for its nuance,
take on wealth inequality, but bonds, June hosts,
scathing critique of modern society goes way beyond its riveting plot points,
which is why today.
We won't be delving into the narrative or the meaning of the title or the
meaning of that. Scholar's rock though, if you want to hear more on that,
be sure to check out the parasite episode of our movie podcast,
show me the meaning. Instead,
we're going to focus on some of the visual details of the film of which even the
smallest elements augment and enhance parasites,
overarching critique fittingly for a film about money.
All of the material things we see on screen from the pizza boxes to the windows
serve an important symbolic purpose.
Let's find out how in this wisecrack addition on parasite, and of course,
spoilers ahead for an Oscar winning best picture that we actually shockingly
agree with. But before we get into it,
I want to give a shout out to Skillshare after work.
I love to sit down and watch a movie or play some video games,
but every once in a while,
I get into this creative groove where I just want to put some work into
developing a new project,
enter Skillshare and online learning community with hundreds of classes on
business design, productivity, freelancing,
and so much more in the past I've recommended classes like Susan Orleans,
creative nonfiction, right truth with style,
which definitely helps people who want to organize their writing.
But I've recently been watching classes that focus a bit more on physical
production in iPhone filmmaking.
I learned about iPhone videography and all the surprising advantages of using
your mobile device to tell a compelling story for just $10 a month.
You can have access to classes like this that will get your creative juices
flowing. It's great.
If you want to bolster up your knowledge about your own field or learn something
completely new,
the first 500 wisecrack fans to click the link in the description and we'll get
a two month premium membership for free.
So start learning and join Skillshare today. And now back to the show,
our guys let's do a quick recap parasite centers around the cunning destitute,
Kim family, who dream of escaping their lousy semi basement apartment.
They scam their way into the lives of the very wealthy park family using
increasingly devious methods to find work as their tutor, art therapist, driver,
and housekeeper things are looking up until they discover they're not the only
family leeching off the parks.
The former housekeepers husband has been camping out in the house's hidden
bunker for years to hide from debt collectors tensions between the two working
class families Mount and everything crescendos at a very bloody birthday party
that leaves several dead after stabbing Mr. Park,
Mr. Kim retreats into the bunker to hide for the foreseeable future. Meanwhile,
the Kim's son fantasizes about earning enough money to buy the house and free
his dad.
That's the bleak weekend appropriately enough for a story revolving around a
hidden basement. Bunker architecture really matters in the film,
the grungy reality of the Kim semi basement apartment contrasts with the
opulence of the parks glamorous home to effectively create two different worlds.
A lot of attention has been paid to the architecture of the houses in part
because the entire movie was filmed on sets built specifically to fit bongs
vision upon closer inspection,
you'll find that every choice made in creating these sets was carefully
calculated.
The Kim's home is based on real semi basement apartments that were built across
sold during the cold war to provide shelter. In case of a North Korean attack,
though,
renting out semi basements was banned for years due to these squalid living
conditions,
South Korea's economic boom led to such overcrowding that the government
relented, we see the poultry living conditions of the camps.
They reside in a dirty concrete building, surrounded by. Stinkbug.
Not a well,
it's a good thing.
To literalize the fact that they are at the bottom rung of the economic ladder.
They live below ground and must walk down a set of stairs to get to their front
door. At the same time.
Everything in the house suggests a solidarity among these family members,
their socks hang from the same hanger and underwear covers the walls of the
bathroom. In contrast,
the Park's house feels definitively not specific to South Korea.
Rather it mimics the modernist style that was originated by Western architects
like Richard Neutra, Louis Kahn, and Frank Lloyd Wright.
The ultimate realization of the modern aesthetic was the glass house and the
Park's home is nearly just that fishbowl like and how much it can reveal.
It also features other modernist touchpoints like a flat rooftop and open floor
plan and an overall minimalist aesthetic. According to art curator,
Donald Albrecht,
modernist architecture as seen in cinema has developed a cluster of connotations
of affluence,
glamor and escape houses that embody that aesthetic of bound in major cities all
over the world from Tokyo to Oslo in a form that credit Kate Wagner has dubbed
the MC modern because of their tendency to each contain the exact same
hodgepodge of modernist design aesthetics. That is,
they all seem to be inspired by the [inaudible] school of architecture
sociologist.
Sunki chai agrees that the home indicates a sort of nouveau Rishi aesthetic and
establishes the parks as not just the 1%,
but the highest level of the 1% the parks as among a select elite who have
managed to succeed in a ruthless capitalist world.
Also fittingly must walk up multiple staircases to access their home.
It's also worth noting that modernist architecture has some pretty deep
cinematic roots. Most playfully identified by designer and writer,
Benjamin Chritton and his books,
evil people in modernist homes and popular films and sad people in modernist
homes and popular films as curtains titles indicate films will frequently depict
modernist homes as the layer of a villain like in blade runner or the big
Lebowski, or even the Incredibles too,
or as a metaphor for the emotionally empty lives of its residents.
As in a single man or the ice storm.
This makes it a fitting home for the park family who though not exactly the
antagonist,
nonetheless emerged as the central subject of bongs class critique their part
villain and their obliviousness to the suffering of those less fortunate.
And they're part tragic figures,
but the mother apparently suffering from substance abuse and the young son
harboring some trauma,
all in all the perfect residents for this modernist Mecca.
We could spend forever talking about the architectural choices in this film.
Take, for example, each house's main window,
the Kim's is short with a severe frame facing offense that gives it a cage like
field.
Part of our view out of the window is obscured by a hanging rack of plain socks
as if to accentuate the fact that in such a cramped space,
every bit wall or ceiling must serve multiple purposes.
What we do see is a garbage filled alleyway where drunken revelers often relieve
themselves. The window is rarely illuminated according to bong,
most semi basement apartments only get about 15 to 30 minutes of natural
sunlight a day.
The film opens with the Kim sun key Wu slouching on an uncomfortable looking
couch,
soaking up a few of these precious rays while struggling to steal wifi access,
not the stuff capitalist dreams are made. In contrast,
we have the jaw dropping floor to ceiling window,
which was designed with a 2.35 to one aspect ratio like a movie theater screen.
It looks out sands any obstruction at an Eden S garden that overflows with
sunlight.
The thought out interior design includes a plush couch to lounge in while gazing
out the window and generally feeling pretty awesome about your life.
That brings us to another seat central difference between the two houses,
the issue of space,
every surface of the Kim's home is cluttered with odds and ends.
Cleaning sprays sits next to a pair of shoes.
Boxes are piled floor to ceiling and the hallway doubles as a closet.
Some proportions of the home seem almost comically conceived like the elevated
toilet, which production designer, Lehigh,
June designed to be as close to the ceiling as possible as if to emphasize the
constant discomfort for the Kim's experience.
The family is frequently crammed together in close proximity as if to emphasize
both the uncomfortable claustrophobia of their conditions and their deep
connectedness. In contrast, the parks home seems to have never known clutter.
The only things we see are strategically intended for display from the wine
fridge to the family,
glamor shot to the sprawling glass cases of pricey dishware,
the small touches of disorder that crop up from time to time like the young park
boys toy arrows are quickly compensated from view by a keen eyed housekeeper
fittingly and Contra the Kims.
The parks are rarely seen in the same room together almost as if the excess of
space has compartmentalized each member.
And unlike the basic layout of the Kim's apartment,
the sprawling design of the park home is rife with hiding spots that make for
easy eavesdropping and glass walls that make for well,
I dropping this suggests that though their house might be welded protected from
the outside world with its fancy video security. Once they craft the family,
like the Kim's make it inside,
the parks are left relatively fence list against their manipulations,
just as architecture helps tell bong story of wealth inequality.
So to do the choices he makes about representing food is an issue
indistinguishable from class,
particularly in a country that has experienced severe food price inflation in
recent years on a basic level,
food serves as an important indicator of wealth and parasite.
At the beginning of the film,
we see the Kim's folding pizza boxes for pizza generation doing low paid labor
for a restaurant that seems to encompass the glow [inaudible] that's made life
in South Korea. So competitive.
It seemed that they can't even afford to eat the pizza. Indeed,
the screenplay notes, the sad empty fridge and Korean food journalist,
Joe McPhearson points out that we see the family early on subsisting on moldy
white bread, cheap chips and F light,
which according to MacPherson is the cheapest milk beverage on the market.
Once the Kim's start working for them,
they gained some disposable income and their rise in class.
This is illustrated by the gradual improvement of their diets. First,
we see them eating at a drivers cafeteria,
which China notes are known for cheap filling buffets that work in class
chauffeurs could enjoy. From there.
We see them kicking back and dining out at pizza generation,
being served by the same employee who previously dock their pay.
They've written from lowly workers to customers.
Eventually they're able to afford beef,
which they cook at home in an LA Golby style. By this point,
three of the family members have progressed to Sapporo beer and expensive import
from Japan, their food journey culminates.
When the parks go on vacation and the Kim's get to play pretend. Yeah,
they're fancy house. They enjoy bottled water from the fridge,
as well as a wide array of classy foods like shellfish, oysters,
and an even wider array of alcohol. Most amusingly key junk,
accidentally nauseous on the parks dog treats confusing them for human food
underscoring.
The fact that the parks pets likely eat better than the Kim's do the parks.
Now Sean colorful plates of intricately arranged fruit,
a particularly expensive commodity in South Korea in contrast that Kim's piled
their plates with rice and vegetables at the buffet for the parks.
Food is a matter of enjoyment for the Kim's.
It's a matter of survival while the Kim's carefully rationed every piece of
bread in their pantry,
the park boy can tear into leftover birthday cake without a second thought at
other points,
food embodies the dichotomy between classes that fuels the film's drama.
Most notably. This happens when Mrs. Park instructs, Mrs. Kim, to cook Ramadan,
a name made up by the films,
English translator to describe a Korean dish that mixes elements of ramen and
UConn Mrs. Park emphasizes that Ramadan should be topped with expensive sirloin
steak and confirms that it's been cooked through before she indulges in an
interview. Bong noted that this choice was very intentional.
This dish is typically seen as a meal for poor folks,
but it happens to be the park boy's favorite dish bawling explains that while
children might not understand the class connotations of food,
the rich wife would still be uncomfortable,
feeding him cheap noodles for dinner.
So she added the Ritz sear sirloin as a topping appropriately.
This means that the pricey sirloin steak sits on a bed of common noodles as if
literally using the message of the film like steak over a bowl of noodles.
The film shows multiple images of wealthy folks, metaphorically,
and literally on top of poor folks,
but there's layer to the interplay of food and class,
mainly because food has played a central and devastating role in the Kim
family's economic history. At one point, the Kims referenced a chicken shop.
They owned that went bust as well as an unsuccessful Taiwanese cake. Shop.
Chicken.
As journalists S Nathan Park notes.
The number of fried chicken joints in South Korea tripled between 2003 and 2013.
And then more than doubled again from 2013 to 2019,
part of this was response to the 1997 Asian financial crisis,
which left many middle-class Koreans without work and forced them to become
self-employed low interest rates made it easy to take out a loan and thousands
took the gamble on opening a mom and pop fried chicken shop of which many like
the Kim's would inevitably fail.
Then the family opened a Taiwanese cake shop attempting to capitalize on a fad
that swept Korea in 2016,
this turned out to be an even more precarious business.
And when the bubble burst thousands of shop owners,
like the Kim's were left bankrupt,
or like the housekeeper and her husband were left deeply in debt in this way,
the references to the family's history,
according to park of a whole world of middle-class failure,
reflecting economic hopes and tragedies that still resonate throughout the
country. It shows us that the Kims weren't always living in poverty.
They were once middle-class business owners,
it was their inability to turn food into a livelihood that ultimately crippled
them.
There's one other aspect of the production design that feels too important,
not to name specifically the array of native American theme toys that the parks
on constantly plays with ranging from a teepee to a head dress,
to a bow and arrow here. We see the boy enjoying American commodities.
The mother even brags that the teepee comes from America,
which chais says probably makes her feel cosmopolitan.
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
Try notes that in South Korea,
there's still a sense that certain things from America are high class,
particularly education aptly Mrs. Park perks up immediately upon hearing that a
potential tutor has been educated at Illinois state university. Well.
[Inaudible], [inaudible].
The same time.
It's interesting that the boy is imitating native American culture rather than
playing say American cops and robbers here.
We think balling is being a bit sly.
The park boy is unknowingly taking on the fashions and cultural objects of a
historically brutally mistreated demographic of Americans for his own amusement.
This only bolsters our sense that the parks exist in a blissful bubble of
privilege. As bong puts it.
The actual history of native Americans is very complicated,
but the mother and the boy don't care about the complexity at all.
It's just a decoration for them. At one point,
the boy sleeps outside in his teepee,
in the rain as if role-playing a less fortunate life than the one he leads
brilliantly and uncomfortably at the exact same moment,
the parks lie on the couch sexually.
Role-playing a scenario in which Mrs. Park selling sex for drugs.
The two simultaneous narratives evoke the family's obliviousness to and
disregard for the realities of living in poverty,
safe and secure in their wealth. Pretending to be poor turns,
a grim brutal way of life into a fun daring game.
Hitting me up, hitting me. Tony will come better.
Parasite creates a modern capitalist fable that warns of the immorality and dark
implications of income inequality, and within the film,
every set prop or slice of pizza contributes a little bit to that message.
But what do you guys think is bong Joon ho a freaking genius is parasite a fun
family, thriller or a subtle invitation to set fire to the system.
Let us know in the comments.
Thanks again to our incredible patrons for supporting our podcasts and the
channel. Go ahead and click that subscribe button and as always,
thanks for watching guys.
[Inaudible].